melange is the spice of spices the
planet Arrakis is its only source the
spice is the most valued commodity in
the universe its price on the Imperial
market has peaked as high as six hundred
and twenty thousand slores
per deca gram the spice is only mildly
addictive when consumed in small
quantities but when taken in quantities
greater than two grams a day per 150
pounds of body weight the spice melange
becomes extremely addictive chiefly
melange is noted for its geriatric
properties the spice extended life but
it was also the key to the prescient
powers of the guild navigators and of MU
Adam when the spice is taken
consistently a person will develop the
eyes of Abad which are characterized by
the whites and pupils of the person's
eyes turning a deep blue the eyes of
Abad indicate a heavy melange addiction
Freeman developed the eyes of a bard as
children others in the Imperium use
cosmetic contacts to hide their blue
within blue eyes melange is formed due
to a chemical reaction of water with the
excretions of San croute underground
when this occurs a precise mass is
formed once the pressure builds this
mass comes rushing to the surface drying
and becoming spice melange the
production of spice is directly tied to
the grapes and worms of Arrakis the
water of life seems to be a chemically
similar but much more potent form of the
spice melange
the liquid is produced when a sandworm
is submerged in water and drowns at the
moment of death an excretion is produced
the water of life the water of life is
poisonous and will kill anyone who
drinks it the mini Jesuit because of
their ability to manipulate their
internal chemistry can alter the
chemical inside of them creating what
the appendix of doom calls a narcotic
awareness spectrum drug a bene Jesuit
Reverend Mother is a sister
who has transformed the illuminating
poison and unlocked her higher awareness
in the process the sisterhood had not
planned for the Fremen to spawn wild
Reverend mothers however who could also
transform the water of life unblocking
their own genetic memory millions of
people throughout the universe are
addicted to spiced safe space travel
depends on its existence without it the
many Jesuit could not be as they are the
spice was first known to be discovered
on Arrakis but who can say where the
first spice was produced in Children of
Dune later the second mentions that the
sand trout were brought to Arrakis from
some other planet meaning that there is
likely another source of the spice
melange or at least once was somewhere
out there in the universe the idea that
the sand worm invasion of Iraqis which
transformed the planet from a lush and
wet world to a barren desert was
accidental
seems odd it had been tried many times
over millennia to allow the sand worms
to proliferate on other worlds but it
had always failed no matter how closely
the conditions were duplicated
this was of course until shayana a
special human who could control the
newer breed of sandworms
who each contained a piece of the god
emperor inside the sandworms require
very specific conditions in order to
thrive it seems like an incredible
stretch of luck that they would end up
on Arrakis a planet which allowed them
to reproduce in great numbers the
honored montrezl who returned out of the
scattering in heretics of doom
appear to have created a substitute to
the spice though it is inadequate in
this time more than 5000 years after
Paul Atreides lived the Tleilaxu also
have the ability to produce spice inside
of their axolotl tanks the bene Jesuit
sisterhood however claimed that the
flail Axew spice is inferior to true
Arrakis spice the spice monopoly had all
but faded into nothingness in this age
before this time however he who
controlled the spice controlled the
universe control of the spice had
allowed Paul Atreides to rise to the
Imperial seat
the spacing guild who alone controlled
space travel followed he who ruled the
spice melange this would all eventually
come to an end however as all things
must
[Music]